>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Good morning.
We have a very special
graphic artist and illustrator
by the name of Jarrett Krosoczka.
I almost got it.
[ Applause ]
And many of you know who he is.
And you've seen books.
And so I'm going to turn the
show immediately over to him.
Jarrett.
>> Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi everybody.
How are you?
>> Good.
>> Good. Well, my name's Jarrett,
and I'm an author and
I'm an illustrator.
So that means that, as the
author, I write the words.
And as the illustrator,
I draw the pictures.
And I feel very lucky
that I can do both jobs.
I get to envision the entire
story because the story's told
with words and with pictures.
And I feel very fortunate
that my books get published
because that means copies of
my books may get to schools
and libraries and bookstores
all across the country.
And I get to meet people
I've never met before,
who've seen some of my books before.
And it's a thrill to know
that these ideas that came
from my imagination
are getting shared
with young readers like yourselves.
So I'm going to talk to you about
how I got my start, and for me,
it all began when I was a kid.
Just like you because,
see, I've been artist
for as long as I can remember.
I don't remember a time in my life
in which I didn't draw pictures.
So this is a self-portrait that
I drew when I was in preschool.
And I drew this picture
with crayons.
Now how many people here have
ever drawn with a crayon before?
Well see, we all started
in the same place.
We all started by drawing
with crayons.
This is the first book
that I ever wrote.
And I wrote this book when
I was in the third grade.
And I remember being a third grader.
And I remember being in class.
And I remember the teacher
presenting this project to us,
where we were going
to write our own book.
We were studying Greek mythology,
and we had to write
our own Greek myth.
And we were going to
write a news story.
And we're going to illustrate it.
And we're going to put
it together as a book.
And this is that book that I
made when I was in third grade.
So this is where my
career as an author began.
Because an author is
somebody who writes a story.
And it doesn't matter if you're
a kid, or if you're a grownup.
It doesn't matter if that
book gets published and a lot
of people get to read it.
Or if you make just one copy of the
book and just one friend reads it.
What matters is that
you write the story.
So how many of you here have
ever written a story before?
Raise your hand, if you ever --
well, then you guys
are all authors, too.
I hope you realize that.
You guys are all authors as well.
Because I was an author when I
was a kid, and there's the proof.
My book had a cover.
When you open up the book, the first
page you saw was the title page.
And then came the story.
And it was a story that was
told using words and pictures.
And this is exactly what I do for my
job today, now that I'm a grownup.
I tell stories with
words and pictures.
And words and pictures
are teammates.
Now they work together.
And one isn't in charge
of the other.
One's not the boss of the other.
Words will tell one
part of the story.
And the pictures, they'll support
that, but then they'll offer
up another aspect of the story that
the words are not communicating.
And sometimes they
make work on their own.
So maybe the words will work
on their own to tell the story.
Maybe the pictures will work
alone to tell the story.
And the very last page of the book
was the about the author page.
And my about the author
page, when I was a kid, read,
Jarrett lives in Worcester,
Massachusetts.
He goes to Gates Lane School.
He liked making this book.
And I love to read
that last sentence.
He liked making this book.
I liked making that book because
I loved using my imagination.
And that's what writing is.
Writing is using your
imagination but on paper.
And I loved using my imagination.
I loved writing so much
that I wouldn't wait
for this to be a school project.
Because when I was young, I
would come home from school
and when I was done with anything
else that needed to be done.
Any homework or chores.
I would take out pieces of paper.
I would fold them in half.
And I would staple them together.
And I would make my own books.
For no other reason but for the
fact that I loved to be creative.
So here are characters
that I would write books
for when I was in the fourth grade.
And I wrote these books
after school on my own.
There was no teacher
giving me an assignment.
There was no grownup at home
saying it's time to make a book.
I did it on my own.
So there was an egg and a tomato
and a head of lettuce and a pumpkin.
And they were friends.
And they went to this
haunted house in one
of the books I wrote
[inaudible] in this haunted house,
there were all sorts of dangers.
There was en evil blender [laughter]
that wanted to chop them up.
There was an evil toaster
[laughter].
And there was an evil microwave
that wanted to melt them up.
I would make my own books.
I'd also make my own comments.
And this was another way for me
to creative, another way for me
to tell stories using
words and pictures.
Here's a comic that I made
when I was in the fifth grade.
Here's another comic that I made
when I was in middle school.
When I got older, when I got to
high school, I continued to draw.
And I took a lot of art
classes in high school.
And in those high school
art classes,
we had to draw a lot of still lifes.
Have you guys ever drawn a
still life in art class before?
It's when -- yeah.
It's when you take an
object, or a group of objects,
and you set it on the table.
And you take out your pad of paper.
And you look at what
you see in front
of you, and you try to draw it.
And it helps you learn
how to draw better.
Well one day, my art teacher
asked us to draw a paper bag.
He said, here's your
homework assignment.
Just go home, get a paper bag.
Set it up in any way you
want to set it up and draw
that book -- draw that picture.
So I took my paper bag
and I cut a face into it.
I set the paper bag up on the
table, and I drew this picture.
Now, this is the picture
I drew as a teenager.
But many years later,
I would go on to write
and illustrate a book called
Baghead that would be published.
So when I was drawing this picture,
I didn't know that I would
someday write that book.
So there's no telling what's
going to happen in the future.
There's no way of knowing how the
work that you're making right now
in your life may inspire
you in the future.
So these characters
that you're drawing now,
maybe you'll find these
papers again in 20 years,
and you'll start drawing them again.
And sending them out
on new adventures.
When I was a teenager, I
got to be the cartoonist
for the high school newspaper.
That was really exciting
because I could come
up with these jokes
and these stories.
They'd be printed in the newspaper.
So kids at my high school
that I didn't even know
were reading my stories.
And that was such a thrill
for me, and it made me realize
that this is what I
wanted to do with my life.
I wanted to share my
stories with people.
I wanted to have my work published.
So even when I was a
senior in high school,
I was still drawing characters
and thinking about books.
So I went to college to study art.
I went to Rhode Island School
of Design to study illustration.
Now before I could get into taking
illustration classes and learning
about drawing characters for books,
I had to take these classes --
they're called foundation classes.
So you're learning
about color and design.
How one color can affect
another color.
How some colors are warm
and some colors are cold.
And how some colors can evoke
different emotions in a viewer.
I had to take drawing classes,
where we were learning
about light and shadow.
We were drawing still lifes to learn
about perspective in architecture.
I had to take painting classes,
where we had to paint still lifes.
We had to paint the models
that would come in and pose.
But just like when I was a kid,
whenever I had some free time,
I would write and illustrate
my own stories.
I always went back to
telling stories with my art.
But those required classes
began to influence my work.
And I started painting
my characters and soon,
I was painting my characters
all the time.
And when I was in college,
every single semester I took
a different writing course.
Because as much as I wanted to
be a professional illustrator,
I also wanted to be a
professional author.
And I wanted to be the one
who would write the stories
for the books I would illustrate.
So I took every single writing
course I could get my hands on.
My most favorite writing
class out of any
of the writing classes I took was
a class called picture and word.
And it was all about picture books.
Writing and illustrating
picture books.
And the big project for
the semester was to write
and illustrate our own book.
And I wrote this book in that class.
It was called Hello Said the Slug.
A story about this orange slug who
wants to be friends with this kid,
and that kid has no patience
for that giant-talking slug.
I was really excited about
how this book turned out.
So much so that when the class was
over, I had this book and I thought
to myself well my teachers
liked the book.
My classmates like the book.
Maybe somebody at a
publisher would like the book.
And if somebody at a publisher liked
the book, they would publish it.
And they would make all of
these copies of the book
that would get sent out to schools
and libraries and bookstores.
And everybody could read my book.
And that would be so exciting.
So I mailed my book
out to a publisher,
and I waited.
And I waited some more.
And I waited some more after that.
But they eventually got back to me.
And guess what happened?
Did they like my book
and publish it?
>> Yes.
>> No. They didn't [laughter].
No. They didn't like my book.
They rejected the book.
That means they mailed
the book back to me.
They wrote me a letter explaining
why they didn't like the book.
But I was lucky they took
the time to explain why.
Bottom line is they said
we're not interested.
So did I give up because
I had one rejection?
>> No.
>> No. Because I mailed that
book out to a second publisher.
And then that second
publisher, they wrote me back.
And did they like the
book and publish it?
>> Yeah. No.
>> No [laughter].
No. They too rejected the book.
But I mailed the book
out to a third publisher,
and did they like the book?
>> Yeah. No.
>> No [laughter].
They too turned the story away.
But I kept trying, and I mailed
the book out to a fourth publisher.
And then a fifth.
And a sixth.
And a seventh.
And an eighth.
And a ninth.
And a tenth publisher.
But they all had the same reaction.
They all said no, we're sorry.
We don't like your book.
We don't want to publish it.
But I didn't give up
and I didn't quit.
And I mailed the book out
to an eleventh publisher,
and guess what happened?
Did they like the book
and publish it?
>> Yeah. No.
>> They did not like
the book [laughter].
And they did not want to publish it.
So there I was with this book
that I loved and I believed in,
but none of the publishers
were interested.
So I kept writing.
And I wrote another story.
I wrote a story called
Josh Had a Bad Haircut.
A story about a boy named Josh
who gets this terribly
embarrassing haircut.
I mailed this book
out to a publisher.
And did they like this new book?
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> No. They didn't [laughter].
Thanks for that vote of
confidence down there, but no.
Every publisher that saw
this book rejected the book.
But in one moment of the story,
on one page of the book, the boy,
he wears a paper bag on his
head to hide the bad haircut.
And that one image was you know
inspired by that picture I drew
as a teenager but would
later inspire me
to write that book Baghead.
That would get published.
This one scene would
later be expanded
to be the whole basis
for this book Baghead.
But all of the books I had written,
though, were all getting rejected.
And so I began to think
it's just my writing.
These publishers don't like my
stories, but maybe they like my art.
And if they like my
art, they would hire me
to illustrate a book
that somebody wrote.
And I thought maybe that's just
how I get my foot in the door.
By drawing pictures for
other authors' books.
So what I would do is [inaudible]
paint a picture like this.
And I would take that picture
-- I'd put it on a postcard.
That postcard would have my art.
My name. And my phone number.
And my e-mail.
My website.
Like information for
carrier pigeons.
Anyway that they wanted to
get a hold of me to hire me
to illustrate a book, they
could get a hold of me.
I printed up 80 of these postcards.
Printed 80 postcards, out to
80 different people at all
of these different publishers.
And how many of those 80
people got in touch with me?
>> One.
>> Well, one is a good
guess, but no.
Fewer than that.
Zero [laughter].
Yeah. Nobody did.
So I painted another picture.
The next week I printed
up another 80 postcards.
And how many people
got in touch with me?
>> Zero.
>> None. And so week after
week and month after month,
I mailed out these postcards,
and I wouldn't hear from anybody.
And it got to the point where
I had been sending my books
out to publishers for two years.
Two years of sending my books
out and getting them rejected.
But I kept writing because
that's what I love to do.
And I wrote a book around that
time called Good Night, Monkey Boy.
About a boy.
He wears monkey pajamas.
He doesn't want to go to bed.
And then I painted this illustration
and I put this illustration
on a postcard.
I printed up 80 postcards.
I mailed them out to 80
different people at all
of these different publishers.
And of the 80 people who
received these postcards,
how many of those 80
people got in touch with me?
>> Zero.
>> One person did.
I received an e-mail from an editor
at Random House Children's Books.
And that's a big publisher.
And I couldn't believe it.
And to give you a perspective
of how long ago this was.
From the time that I turned
on my computer till I
could download the e-mail,
it took me 20 minutes [laughter]
because that's what life
was like in the late '90s.
You had to connect to a phone line.
There was an awful sound.
But 20 minutes later, after turning
on the computer, I got this e-mail
from somebody at Random House.
And the subject of the
e-mail said nice work.
And I couldn't believe it.
And in this e-mail,
this editor wrote
that she had received my postcard.
And it prompted her to visit my
website, and she liked my artwork.
And she said, if you're ever in
New York City, please let me know.
We'd love to meet you and
see some more of your work.
So do you guys suppose that
I happened to be in New York
that next week [laughter]?
>> Yeah. I called her the next
day to say I'm going to be
in New York that next week.
And we set up a meeting.
And I went into New
York with my portfolio.
And I showed this editor
all of my artwork,
and I showed her all
of my book ideas.
And I left New York
with an agreement
to have my very first
book published.
So Good Night, Monkey Boy was a book
that I only had started
writing a couple weeks,
really, before that meeting.
But because I kept
coming up with new ideas.
I kept challenging
myself creatively.
I kept sending my work out.
That is how my first
book was published.
So I kept writing picture books.
And the books that my
publisher liked, they published.
Like Baghead.
And Punk Farm.
And My Buddy, Slug.
And Ollie, the Purple Elephant.
I have a collection
of picture books.
And I also have a graphic
novel series
about a lunch lady who fights crime.
So the very first book
was called Lunch Lady
and the Cyborg Substitute, and it
was followed up by nine other books
for a total of 10 books
in the series.
The most recent book is Lunch
Lady and the Schoolwide Scuffle.
And I'm going to tell you now.
I'm going to shift gears.
And now that I've told you about how
I got published, I'm going to talk
to you about how I got
the idea for the series.
And what I did with those ideas
to turn them from just a few notes
in my sketchbook to
be a book series.
What happened was way back, when
my very first book was published.
I went back to my old elementary
school, Gates Lane School
in Worcester, Massachusetts, to talk
to the students there about writing
and illustrating and having
that first book published.
And they set me up
in the cafetorium.
You know what a cafetorium
is [inaudible]?
Yeah. Half cafeteria,
half auditorium,
depending on what's going
on at school that day.
And I had a slide projector.
You can ask your teachers --
maybe The Library of Congress has
one [inaudible] slide projector
looks like, so you could see what
this was like back in the day.
Way before iPads and
digital projection.
And so I had a slide projector, and
I'm setting up my slide projector.
And I looked across the
cafetorium, and there she was.
My old lunch lady.
She was busy working and getting
lunches ready for school that day.
So I had to stop what I was doing.
I went over to say hello.
And I said hi Jeannie, how are you?
You know, she looked at me, and
I could tell she recognized me.
The gears were turning.
She was trying to place me.
And she looked at me, and
she said Stephen Krosoczka?
And I was amazed that she
knew I was a Krosoczka.
But Stephen is my uncle, who's 20
years older than I am [laughter].
And she had been his lunch
lady when he was a kid.
So she started telling me about
her grandkids, and it blew my mind.
I thought grandkids?
Wait a minute.
You mean you leave the school
and have a life [laughter]?
I thought you lived in the kitchen.
I had never thought about my lunch
lady's life outside of school.
And this chance encounter
inspired my imagination.
And I opened up my sketchbook
when I got home that day,
and I started drawing
this lunch lady character.
And I wrote a picture
book, not a graphic novel.
A picture book.
Remember my first picture
book had just been published.
I had just finished the art for
Baghead, which was my second book.
Which was a picture book.
So I thought lunch lady was meant
to be a picture book as well.
And it was a story about kids
who sat at their lunch table
and debated what they thought
their lunch lady did after school.
And whatever their
flights of fantasy were,
you would see that in the art.
So if one kid said our lunch
lady's an opera singer.
And you would turn the page, and
you would see that in the art.
One of the students thought well,
maybe our lunch lady is a spy.
And she knows karate.
And she keeps the school safe.
And that quickly became the
more interesting story to tell.
The story of a lunch lady who is
actually secretly a super hero.
And she's like a spy
in the cafeteria.
But now that story
would no longer fit
into the format of a picture book.
A picture book is only
32 pages long.
And now that I'm dealing with a
story of heroes versus villains
and mysteries that would need to
be solved, I'd need a longer book.
And I wasn't sure what
kind of book it would be.
And that didn't matter.
What mattered was the story.
What mattered was the character,
and the characters that
would surround her.
So in my sketchbook, over
the next several years,
I just kept drawing this character.
At one point I thought it was
supposed to be a chapter book.
That didn't
seem like the right fit either,
but I kept drawing the character,
thinking about how
she'd get around town.
How she'd go undercover.
I started thinking about who
the other characters were.
So she has an assistant named
Betty, who helps her fight crime.
She has these three meddling kids
that you know they
help her fight crime,
even though she doesn't
want them around.
She thinks they're
going to blow her cover.
But there's Hector,
Terrence and Dee.
And they're the breakfast bunch,
and they become involved
in the mysteries.
And she uses items from the
cafeteria [laughter] disguised
as spy gadgets.
So she has a spork phone.
She has a spatu-copter.
She has fish stick nun chucks.
Because see, if you saw your
lunch lady walking down the hall
with nun chucks, you
would tell your friend,
and that friend would
tell another friend.
Those two friends -- and
then before you knew it,
the whole school would know that
your lunch lady is a crime fighter.
So she has to have her spy
gadgets disguised as things
that you would see
a lunch lady with.
Like fish sticks.
She has a milk camera
to spy on the classroom.
She has rubber glove suction
cups to climb the walls
with her yellow rubber gloves.
She has a lunch tray laptop.
Now it was around this time
that I was invited to be a part
of this book called Guys Write
for Guys Reading [phonetic].
Which is edited by John Cheska.
And he asked his author friends
to make a little contribution
to this anthology.
Everyone would write a couple
of pages' worth of stuff.
And he wanted us to
connect ourselves
with our younger selves
to our current selves.
So I thought as an artist, I
would revisit some old artwork.
Now I'm very lucky that every year
my grandfather would give me a
storage bin.
He'd say save what you want.
And then we're going to
throw the rest of it --
clean your room and
throw things away.
So I was going through these bins,
and I found comics that I made
as an elementary school student.
I found comics that I made
as a middle school student.
And as a high school student.
I found comics that I
made as a college student.
But once my first picture
book was published,
I'd kind of stopped making comics.
So I found this comic that
I made in the fifth grade
about a character named
Lightning Man.
And I realized I didn't
finish his story.
So for Guys Write for Guys
Read, I continued his story.
I completed his story and not only
was I redrawing a character I hadn't
drawn in so many years, I remembered
what I loved about making comics.
And what you can do
with the storytelling.
And the action.
And the pacing.
And the humor.
With that visual storytelling
format.
And I said well, this is perfect
for the story that I've been working
on for the past four and a
half years at that point.
Four and a half years of sketching.
A story about a crime
fighting lunch lady.
I sent these pages
off to my publisher.
They loved the idea.
They wanted to publish the book.
But they weren't sure how to because
they hadn't published graphic
novels then.
They didn't have any
graphic novels on their list
that they were publishing.
So they thought well, could we
print these books in full color?
And they realized they really
couldn't because it cost a lot
to print a book in full color.
And they didn't want to put a book
out to stores and libraries for $15.
So we thought what if these books
were printed in just black ink?
And they'd be printed in you
know just black and white.
And so the production
costs would be low,
so the retail cost would be low.
But the fear was there's no color
to really draw the reader in.
So ultimately, we decided to
print the book in just two inks.
Black ink and we would
choose a second color
that would become the
signature color for the series.
And we chose yellow
because that is the color
of the iconic dishwashing
rubber glove [laughter].
So now these books are going
to happen, I need to know how
to draw these characters, and
every time I draw the character,
it needs to look like
the same person.
So I draw the character over and
over and over and over again.
And I train myself
so every time I draw
that character it looks
like the same person.
Then I set out to write the story.
Now I've done about five years
of brainstorming at this point.
And I like to spend more
time you know brainstorming.
Sketching out the characters.
Getting to know their personalities.
Before I start worrying
too much about the plot.
But when I start, I'm
ready for the plot.
I used this device
called a story mountain.
And it helps me -- as a visual
thinker and a visual learner,
I like to see the whole
story mapped out.
And I think about the beginning.
The rising action.
And the climax.
And the falling action.
And the resolution of the story.
And it's important for me to point
out to you that when I start off
with this blank story
mountain, I don't start here.
I don't have to answer the question
of what happens in the beginning.
Because maybe the first idea
is the climax of the story.
So I could jot that down first.
And I just keep coming up
with ideas and brainstorming
because I don't need to dream
up the story in the same order
that my reader will
eventually read it.
I dream up the story, and
I rearrange those elements
of the story how I see fit
to be revealed to the reader.
And I make page after
page of notes to myself
on what I want to happen
in the story.
And I lay out the book.
So a 96-page graphic novel,
I make 96 little rectangles,
and I try to figure out what
event will happen on which page.
And you can see I'm
moving things around.
And I'm taking arrows and saying
no, this event should happen here.
This event should happen
earlier or later.
And every page starts
off looking like this.
This is a small thumbnail sketch
where I'm trying to figure
out where the panels are
going to go because I need
to recreate the reading experience.
Like when you open up a book that
has text only, your eye goes where?
Your eye goes to the
top left of the page.
Right? And your eyes scan from left
to right, and then when you get
to the end of the sentence,
your eye goes back down
and you scan from left to right.
So I have to, as the designer of the
graphic novel, design these panels
to visually recreate
that experience.
So people just naturally know
where to send their eyes.
And then when it comes to designing
the information within those panels,
I have to do the same thing.
So that people read
it from left to right.
So I make 96 pages'
worth of sketches.
I'll also write out a script.
A script is just what the
characters are saying,
descriptions of the actions.
My editor will read this.
She'll read the script.
She'll look at the sketches.
She'll think about it.
And she'll write me
an editorial letter,
stating this is what's
working [inaudible]
but this part here,
maybe not so much.
So she's pushing me to
write a better book.
So I listen to her advice,
and I revise the story.
And I'll write a second draft.
And I'll make some changes.
And she'll read that second draft.
And then maybe the third
draft, maybe a fourth, fifth.
Sometimes up to eight drafts.
But when the story's in great shape,
I can start working on the artwork.
And to create the artwork
for the books,
I start by just penciling
out the characters.
And I use a special pencil
called non-photo blue.
It's the special shade of blue that
won't get recognized by the scanner.
Because what I do is I take out ink
and I dip my brush into the ink.
And I ink in the final line work.
And I scan that artwork
into black and white,
and the computer will only
see the black line work.
The computer won't see all
of those sketchy lines.
Which is why you don't see
them in the finished books,
but they're underneath
there in the finished art.
So I always start off by drawing
the major shapes of the character.
Every character is made
up of a series of shapes.
And I'm creating the gesture.
The gesture means what
is the character's pose?
And I'll add details on top of that
gesture, and I can make changes.
So maybe her arm should go
in a different direction.
I'll then take out my ink, and
I'll dip my brush into the ink
and draw the finished line work.
And I draw with a brush because
you get a very dynamic line
when you draw with a brush.
If you apply a lot of
pressure to that brush,
that line is going to be very thick.
As you lift the pressure away, that
line will go from thick to thin.
So as I finish each
piece of artwork,
I collect on a bulletin board in
front of my desk so I can see all
of the artwork and make sure all of
the characters are looking the same.
Make sure the environment that
they're in looks the same.
And I take the artwork,
bring it over to my scanner,
and scan it into my computer.
So now this artwork
that I created by hand,
I can see on my computer screen.
And you'll see that all of
the word balloons are empty.
I don't handwrite the words.
I type them out.
And once all of the
text is in place,
I'll select the different
shades of yellow,
and all of the yellow
will get plugged in.
And then I tone down that black
ink to get shades of gray.
So 96 computer files for
the 96 pages of the book.
I send those to the publisher
through the internet.
They print out just
one copy of the book.
They're not going to print up
all the copies to distribute them
to bookshelves just
yet because we want
to make sure there
are no mistakes here.
There's bound to be
a mistake or two.
So perhaps I've misspelled
a sound effect.
Maybe there's something
weird about the art.
Maybe something is miscolored.
And we'll make notes to one
another on this one copy.
And I'll have one last
chance to open up Photoshop
and make any changes, before these
files are released to the printer.
And they print up all of the copies.
And this is the most exciting step.
This is the -- up until this point,
this has been thoughts and notes.
I've yet to be able
to hold the book.
Hold the object and turn the pages
and watch the story unfold,
as I imagined it might.
Now from that moment that I ran into
my old lunch lady and to the day
that I held this book in my
hands, eight years have passed.
It was a number of
years of brainstorming.
To sticking with it.
Getting the artwork done
for that first book.
But like I said, now there
are 10 books all together.
So ten 96-page
graphic novels.
And this is what all of
the artwork looks like.
For all of the books.
I just recently moved, so I was
stacking up all of the artwork.
And I looked at it,
and I thought wow,
that represents a significant
percentage of my life.
I've been working on the
series now for 13 years now.
But it's been very
rewarding because I get
to meet young readers
who've read the books.
Who know the characters.
Who know the stories.
And I get physical mail.
I get tweets from parents
and teachers of kids
who are reading the books
in the printed form and kids
who are reading them on tablets.
And I get wonderful letters
and drawings from kids.
And they're drawing the
way that I was drawing.
I learned how to draw
when I would draw my --
I would draw Garfield,
or I would draw Snoopy.
I'd draw some of my
favorite characters.
[ Inaudible Response ]
And the American Library Association
invited me to design a read poster.
So I designed this poster,
and I spot it at libraries,
as I travel the country.
A kid once trick-or-treated
at my house [laughter] dressed
as my character, which
was pretty cool.
And I was lucky enough that twice,
a lunch lady book has won a
Children's Choice Book Award.
And it's such an honor
to win any award.
But to win an award that's voted
on by the readers themselves
because then my readers
put my name up in lights
in Times Square because of that.
And, of course, I meet a lot
of lunch ladies [laughter],
as I travel the country, you know.
And they tell me how much
the series means to them.
Because the lunch lady
-- in popular culture,
the lunch lady isn't
treated very kindly.
You know often you see a cartoon
character [inaudible] lunch lady
and maybe they're mean or not
nice, or serve awful food.
And you know a lunch lady
in your real life you know.
That couldn't be further
from the truth.
And it meant a lot to
my old lunch ladies.
I gave them artwork when the
books were first published
at the book signing in Worcester.
And I later learned how much that
acknowledgement meant to them,
and I was really touched and moved
by how much that meant to them.
So I created a day called
School Lunch Hero Day.
It's the first Friday in May.
We've celebrated twice so far.
It's a day where kids can
tap into their own creativity
to say thank you in
however way they choose.
So kids came up with
the greatest projects.
This student made a hamburger card.
This classroom, they made a pizza
and every student signed a
pepperoni to say thank you.
Kids made their own comics,
starring the cartoon lunch lady
and their actual lunch lady.
So they asked their lunch
lady to pose for photos,
and they printed them out
and put them in there.
And I just saw you know through
social media and people emailing me,
these wonderful smiles from
all across the country.
But then politicians get involved.
And this is something
I wasn't expecting,
but people started
sending me news clippings,
where you know senators stopped
by their local elementary school.
Lieutenant governors stopped by.
The mayor of Houston sent
out an official legal proclamation
[laughter] proclaiming it School
Lunch Hero Day in the
city of Houston.
And Michelle Obama's Let's
Move program has blogged
about encouraging their members,
and the people that are involved
with their program and
reading their blog,
to celebrate School Lunch Hero Day.
And it all goes back to the fact
that I was a kid just
like all of you.
I love stories.
I loved reading stories.
I loved getting to know characters.
And I loved inventing
my own characters
and writing stories for them.
And I'm always working
on new stories.
So I have a new picture book
that was just published earlier
this year called Peanut Butter
and Jellyfish.
About a seahorse and a jellyfish
that are best friends and a crab,
who isn't exactly nice to them.
But they kind of get to the bottom
of why he's behaving the way he is.
And I have a chapter book series
called Platypus Police Squad.
It's about these two cops,
detective Rick Zengo.
He's the hotshot young rookie, who
plays fast and loose with the rules.
And he's partnered with
the old gruff old-timer,
who sort of lost his spark
named detective Corey O'Malley.
They're total opposites.
They need to learn to work
together to keep the city safe.
And they're platypuses.
And the first book is
called The Frog Who Croaked.
The second book is called
The Ostrich Conspiracy.
And the third book, which
I'm working on now at home,
is called Last Panda Standing.
I'm also the proud coeditor of
an anthology called Comic Squad,
which recently was published.
And you guys know Matt
and Jenny Holm
who create Squish and Babymouse?
You know those books, right?
So they're good friends of mine.
And we were talking online one
day about comics and kids' comics.
And the comics that we loved
when we were young and how,
wouldn't it be great if there was
an anthology that could team people
up to make little short stories?
And we thought well, you know what?
Instead of saying somebody
should do that.
We said well, we'll do it.
And we came up with the theme
of recess for the first book.
So every cartoonist
made a little mini comic
around the theme of recess.
And Dave Pilkey who created
Captain Underpants made a piece.
And Raina Telgemeier who
created Smile, did a piece.
And Dave Roman and Dan Santad.
And we're really proud of the book.
And actually we have a new roster.
There's a second comic
squad, and we're gathering
up other cartoonists, as well.
Here's a shot of my old studio.
Like I said I just moved but --
so picture all of that same stuff,
but just in a different
configuration,
and that's where I work.
But this desk, too -- I should tell
you this desk was a birthday present
for my 14th birthday.
And I still work on it today.
And for the teachers in the
room, my website has a lot
of resources there
for your classrooms.
You could download radio interviews
I conduct with my author friends.
You can download the books
that I wrote as a kid, myself.
And for you guys, we
have some time left,
and I'm going take some
questions from you.
I want to hear from you
guys, and then I'm going
to draw some pictures for you.
Do you have a question
for me, back there?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> How do you get the idea?
>> For which book?
For lunch lady?
It all -- that chance encounter
with my old lunch lady.
Sometimes something in reality
will get you to start to think
about the fantastic, and
that's where that came from.
My friend back here.
>> What's your favorite
book that you wrote?
>> What's my favorite
book that I wrote?
Well it's kind of like -- it's
kind of like asking a parent
who their favorite child
is [laughter], you know?
I love all of my books the same.
And I really do.
Each character -- you know each
book represents a different time
in my life.
Like you know Good Night Monkey
Boy was my first published book.
And I wrote that book
15, 16 years ago
and my life was very
different 15, 16 years ago.
Yes? My friend right here.
[ Inaudible Question ]
What inspired me to write
the lunch lady books?
It's just I wanted
to uncover the truth
about what lunch ladies were
really up to [laughter].
I think I'm on to something.
Do you think -- how is your
lunch staff at your school?
Do you think they're
secretly hiding something?
No? Well you should ask questions.
That's how you find out things.
Ask questions.
Yeah. Beyond saying I'll have
the chicken patty, please.
And be like and what is,
what is that box over there?
What is that doing [laughter]?
See how -- if they act shifty.
Do you know what that means?
Where they're like they're nervous,
then they're probably
hiding something.
Yes. My friend right here.
>> What gave you the
idea to be an author?
>> Why did I want to be an author?
I love using my imagination.
I just -- I like making things up.
I like creating these
fantastic stories.
And that's my need and
want to create made me want
to be an author [inaudible].
You do too?
That's great.
Yes. My friend right here.
>> How do you pronounce your name?
>> My last name is
pronounced Krosoczka.
Krosoczka.
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Why do you want
to be a [inaudible]?
>> Well, you know what?
If my -- if on that day that I
revisited my old elementary school,
if my old -- say the old
janitor was still there
and we strike up a conversation.
Maybe it would have
been about janitors.
But it was that I ran
into my old lunch lady
and I started thinking how?
Like what does she do?
And no one would suspect
the lunch lady.
No one would suspect her
to be the crime fighter.
My friend here in the white shirt.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Oh, in the beginning of a series.
Wow. That's a got you question.
I'm working on the third
Platypus Police Squad book.
So where I'm at with that is
that I've written the story.
And my editor and I are going back
on revisions for the chapters.
And I have up to chapter
seven sketched out,
but there are 23 chapters.
So not only do I have to sketch
out everything, but then I have
to go back and create the finished
artwork for those sketches.
And then I'm working on a
picture book called It's Tough
to Lose Your Balloon.
And it's about all the
injustices of childhood.
Losing your balloon.
Dropping your sandwich in the sand.
You know having your ice cream
cone melt right when you've got it,
or you just picked up your ice cream
from the ice cream
truck and then it melts.
So it's about the injustices
of childhood
and how you can rise above those
challenges.
Yes. My friend right there.
>> Then do you make money
by selling those books?
>> I'm lucky enough.
That yeah, people will
end up buying them.
And then my publisher will give me
a couple of cents off each book.
Yeah, I'm lucky.
It's called a royalty.
So what it is.
So I created like this book, right?
And I -- so I came
up with the ideas,
and I wrote the words
and drew the pictures.
So that means that I own the --
what's called intellectual
property or the copyright.
So when someone buys the book.
You know you bought
this physical book.
And my publisher worked hard
on printing this physical book
and shipping it to the stores.
So because I own the copyright,
I'll get what's called a royalty
or a little percentage off of that.
Yes?
>> How did you come up with
all the different titles?
>> All the different titles.
Well, in the lunch lady series,
I was thinking about okay,
what else happens in
a young person's life?
Maybe you go to summer camp.
Maybe there's a visiting author.
Maybe it's picture day.
But all of the titles have
alliteration in the title.
So Lunch Lady and the
Cyborg Substitute --
alliteration is where two words
start with the same sound.
So there's cyborg substitute.
League of librarians.
The author visit vendetta.
Schoolwide scuffle.
So as a challenge [inaudible]
okay what happens in a kid's life?
What's sounds dastardly?
And what has alliteration?
And that's how I came
up with the titles.
Yes?
>> Well I have a whole list
of books [inaudible] so far,
we only have the lunch lady books.
So I'm really happy to see your
other books, right [inaudible]?
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay [inaudible].
Okay.
>> What did you read?
>> What did I read when I was a kid?
>> Like what's your
favorite book or --
>> Oh my --
>> That made you --
>> My --
>> Who you are?
>> My favorite books
when I was a child.
I still have my childhood copies
on my bookshelf in my studio.
My most favorite book,
most favorite, is The Mouse
and the Motorcycle
by Beverly Clearly.
Yes. Absolutely.
And James and Giant
Peach by Roald Dahl.
And Bunnicula by James Howe.
Bunnicula.
>> Oh Bunnicula.
>> Sorry James Howe,
if you see this.
Whoever, they can dub in
-- we read that book too.
And then every day, I would get
the newspaper from my grandfather.
And I would go right
to the comic section.
And for two years I
would cut out Garfield,
and I would make my own
treasuries in photo albums.
And I read Calvin and Hobbs.
And I read comic books
like X-Men and Spiderman.
Those all make up what
you see here today.
My friend right here.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Was I able to give her a copy?
Yes. She came to that
very first book signing,
and I gave her a piece
of artwork and the book.
So she got to see the books,
and she was pretty thrilled.
And I think she was taken
aback by the whole thing.
My friend here in the blue shirt.
[ Inaudible Question ]
I'm sorry, could you say that again?
What inspired me to make
pictures when I was a kid?
Well, it probably goes
back to what I read.
So I loved Snoopy.
I loved Garfield.
I loved Calvin and Hobbs.
You know I loved the Smurfs and
other characters I [inaudible]
on Saturday morning cartoons.
So what I would do is
to help me learn how
to draw is I would
say take a picture.
Take a drawing of a
smurf or of Snoopy.
And I would try to copy it,
and that taught me how to draw.
And then that knowledge I gained
from copying those drawings,
I then went on to draw
my own characters,
which you saw on the slide show.
Our friend right here.
>> What's your favorite
gadget [inaudible]?
>> My favorite gadget.
I don't have a favorite book,
but I have a favorite gadget.
It's the fish stick nun chucks.
And this is why they're my favorite.
Because not only do they
look like fish sticks.
They smell like fish
sticks [laughter].
And my friend right here.
[ Inaudible Question ]
What was the most fun?
You know, I'm not sure any
one book is the most fun.
I will say, though, I have a
picture book called Punk Farm.
Where [inaudible] farm animals, and
they have these punk rock concerts.
And their stage is always lit
with like these crazy colors.
Like oranges and pinks and purples.
And I had a lot of fun
painting those pictures.
I mean to be able to wake
up and say my job today is
to paint [inaudible] guitar.
Like that's what I need to do
today is a pretty remarkable thing.
My friend back here in the blue.
[ Inaudible Question ]
What was my favorite
scene in the Lunch Lady?
I don't know if I have one
favorite scene, but I had a lot
of fun creating the scene in
Lunch Lady and Bake Sale Bandit.
There's a school bus robot
dragon monster thing.
And even just saying
that is fun [laughter].
So imagine getting to draw that.
My friend here in the blue.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Which bad guys did I
have the most fun with?
Probably the evil children's
book author.
The second book was called
League of Librarians,
and I thought the librarians better
know that I'm willing to make fun
of authors as well [laughter].
Equal, yeah.
A few more questions.
Yep.
[ Inaudible Question ]
That's a good question.
If I ever get frustrated by what
I'm working on, the best thing
to do is just walk away
and do something else.
Maybe I might walk my dog and
get outside for a little bit.
I'm trying to every day
make a piece of art --
that maybe it only takes
me 10 minutes to do,
but it's something not to do with
the art I need for the books.
Because to write and to illustrate.
There's so many things
you have to think about.
You have to think about your space.
You need to think about
how you feel, too.
So getting you know good exercise
and making sure you're eating right.
You know that's -- all
of those things factor
into the work that you make.
Now I know there's so many other
people with their hands raised,
but I want to be able to draw
some pictures for you guys.
And I'm going to give
you guys a couple
of little drawing lessons here.
Now I mentioned in my slide
talk that when I'm at home
and I'm working on the art
for these finished books,
I have a special pencil
called non-photo blue.
And if I were to draw with
a non-photo blue pencil,
you wouldn't be able to
see those marks from afar
because it's a very faint
mark, very faint line.
So I have this light blue marker
that will sort of stand in for that,
to give you an idea of what
the process looks like.
So like I said, every character
is made up of a series of shapes.
So when I'm drawing lunch lady,
I start off by drawing
an upside-down teardrop
and then a regular-ended teardrop.
And I'm drawing the gesture.
The gesture is like
where the limbs are.
Like how the character is posed.
And I'm going to have her
jumping through the air.
So I think about where her legs go.
Not a lot of detail yet, is there?
Because it's a lot easier
to make changes now.
So if I were to start by drawing
the details of the character's eyes
and face and I would get to the end.
And I said I want to make a change.
But I spent all that time and
all that work on the detail.
Because now I can look at
that and say, you know what?
I'm going to make her head a
little bit smaller, like so.
So now on top of that gesture
sketch, I'll layer the details.
So I have the character's hair.
And eyes and face.
And I'm pretty loose with my marks.
Close her gloves.
Her sleeves.
So once I have a good foundation
down, then I would take out my ink.
And again, when I'm at home, I take
a brush, and I dip it into ink.
That would be logistically
difficult.
And I flew here by
airplane this morning.
I would need something
smaller than 4 ounces.
I have a big old ink jar there.
So, I going to use a Sharpie
marker as a stand-in for that.
[ Drawing ]
And again, when this artwork
-- when it gets scanned in,
and I set that scanner
to black and white,
the computer doesn't register
the blue pencil marks.
It only registers -- it can only
see that crisp black line work.
[ Drawing ]
So, if you were ever able to get a
look at some of the original artwork
up close, you would see all
of the underworking
underneath all of the art.
But you don't see that in the books.
You just see the finished lines.
So you may have been under the
assumption that I start off
by drawing the lines that
intricate and that's spot-on.
But you see, I allowed
myself to make some mistakes
with the pencil before
I went to the final art.
[ Drawing ]
My signature and the year.
So there's lunch lady, but she --
there's another character that's
very important to the story.
And where lunch lady is made
up of a series of teardrops,
there's someone else who's
made up of a series of circles.
And every character
is made up of shapes.
And when you boil it down
to just the main shapes,
your audience could
probably tell who that is.
Does anybody know who this is?
That's amazing.
Thank you for knowing that.
That's her sidekick Betty.
All I drew was a circle and a
bell, and you knew who it was.
[ Background Conversations ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now that you've applauded,
I hope I don't mess
up the rest of this [laughter].
You can't take back that
applause, no matter what I do.
It's mine now.
[ Drawing ]
Okay. So, well thank you.
[ Applause ]
I'm going to leave you with
one final lesson before we go.
And this lesson that I'm
going to give you, too,
you can apply to your
characters that you're inventing.
And we're going to
talk about emotions.
Because illustration is all about
visually communicating the story.
So how a character
feels is communicated
by their facial expression.
So could you show me with
your faces, just your faces,
what does it look like
when you're really happy?
When you're really
happy, you smile real big.
You can see your teeth.
And when you smile, your lips
push up and your cheeks push up,
and it creates a little
line underneath the eyes.
[ Drawing ]
Like so.
And there, with the
character looks happy.
Could you please show me --
show me what it looks like
when you're really angry.
You're angry.
Your eyebrows cross.
And what happens is your eyebrows
are pushing together towards the
center of your face, and it's
wrinkling up your forehead a bit
And you also -- you were so angry --
you were so angry that you
tilted your heads down.
And you were looking up.
So you can have those angry
eyebrows with that little line,
but see how there's space
between the eyes and the eyebrows?
It's not going to be the case here.
Those eyebrows are going to be
covering the very top of the eyes
because your head is tilted down.
[ Drawing ]
Show me what it looks like
when you're really sad.
Like it was just an awful day.
You're really sad.
Your eyebrows.
Okay, your eyebrows all came up.
[ Background Conversations ]
And you all pouted a little
bit with your lips right there.
[ Background Conversations ]
Now show me what it looks like --
show me what it looks like
when you're scared [yelling].
Your eyes all got really big.
Your eyes got really big.
And the trick to showing
that a character is scared is
that not only are the eyes bigger
but the pupils are smaller.
[ Drawing ]
[ Laughter ]
Now there are so many other
emotions that we could cover.
And I encourage you to explore those
on your own by just sitting in front
of a mirror and making faces.
Actually when I'm at home, my family
catches me doing this all the time.
I'll be drawing.
And I'm making the face of the
character that I'm drawing.
I'm becoming that character.
But now this applies if
your character is human,
or if your character
is maybe a lion.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe a pig.
Maybe a space alien.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe an elephant.
And with an elephant, I can use
that trunk to show the emotion.
Or if I were drawing a rabbit,
I could use those ears to show
that the character was
sad or surprised or happy.
So out of everything that I
talked about this morning,
what I hope that you remember the
most is that my career, my journey,
as an author and as an artist,
began when I was your age.
And I want you to make sure that
you consider yourselves authors
and illustrators.
And that please don't wait for
this to be a school assignment.
Because it does not need
to be a required thing
because it's so much fun.
It's so much fun to
use your imagination.
Escape from your real
life for a little bit.
And take a blank piece of paper
and pour your imagination
out onto that paper.
So after school, on your own,
without any grownup asking you to,
get a hold of some paper
and make awesome things.
Okay? Thank you guys so much,
and thank you the Young Reader
Center for having me today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.